moi je viens me sentir mon premier titre
en français qui s'appelle tik tok tik
tok
peux tu nous raconter l'histoire de
cette chanson qu'elle est un vision
poussé titre dans l'histoire de cette
chanson c'est été fêté au studio et j'ai
rencontré jeudi au mas et 10 et jordan
j'avais aussi jo puisque c'est la fois
un peu on a beaucoup rigolé un sit in à
conserver des preuves et gecko j'ai
entendu tip top 10 ans que j'ai commencé
à faire des free style et et gilot ma
vie j'ai été j'ai enregistré tous tout
ce que vous entendez la tic toc c'est un
freestyle et ensuite la structure et
s'installe chez sade en anglais alors et
a ainsi dit la structure mais ça c'est
la voile a commencé à traduire et les
cas un français et est ce que ça c'était
super ville super vahid naturelle à
paris c'était cool et aussi de quoi
d'autre ces conditions pour ce site
je pense que le manceau j'étais un
prénom j'étais en train de passer un
moment très paresseux je voulais pas
bosser j'étais fatigué je bossais sur
mon projet en français the do et
apprendre une langue c'est estelle
beaucoup et j'étais fatigué ça c'est
avant le confinement en janvier et en
fait je pense que j'avais besoin d'une
motivation sur le sujet je pense que ce
morceau de l'asec s'assécher l'objectif
c'est que ça soit une motivation à tout
le monde parce que moi j'avais pas envie
de bosser
jeudi me dit rien eastick toc toc toc
toc
le temps passe le temps parce qu'ici tu
bosses pas tu vas tomber si tu veux tu l
entends tu devais la plus forte si tu
veux vraiment faire ce que tu fais et
fernand jean rigaud et sports a lancé et
je pense que maintenant que j'ai pu
palais avait à gagner 110 cas je pense
que les à ce qu'ils écoutent ça c'est ça
c'est ça qui fait la queue
donc ça c'est les gens je veux que copé
parlait 16 ou parler si vous voulez pas
bosser et vous êtes fatigué que vous
prenez deux minutes et demie et vous
écoutez tic toc et je suis sûr que ça va
vous motiver à faire du sport en au
travail après la chose que tu voulais
faire depuis trois mois et un complice à
tik tok c'est de la motivation